Donald Trump's disapproval has exploded in
the last two weeks and there seem to be two
big factors.
Number one, Trump's just tragically, historically
disastrous response to the recent mass shootings.
Uh, and then in addition to that, you've got
the continued recession fears and stock market
crashes.
800 points lost on the dowel yesterday.
More than a 3% decline there.
And on the Nasdaq and on the s and p 500 and
Donald Trump just continues to tweet nonsense
about the economy and about trade and about
who's to blame.
And the most amazing thing about all of this
is that a Fox News poll finds that Trump is
really not doing well.
Fox just released a presidential approval
poll, which has trumpet 56% disapproval.
Now, before I go any further, it's shocking
that it's only 56% in other words, the fact
that only 56% of the country disapproves of
the job Trump is doing is a real red flag
about tens of millions of people in our country.
But needless to say, this has now basically
tied to the record for the highest Trump disapproval.
The point here is the trendline.
Trump's disapproval is up five full points
from last month.
And again, it's back to essentially statistically
matching the record high disapproval Trump
has had during his presidency, which was October
of 2017 nearly two years ago.
And the timing of this from an electorial
perspective could be good as we start to get
into the 2020 election in full.
And meanwhile, Donald Trump continues to do
nothing substantive, uh, about, uh, economic
policy obviously because he doesn't understand
it.
He continues to do nothing substantive about
the gun violence issues in the United States.
And the same Fox News poll found that two
thirds of Americans, this is a significant
majority in such a hyper-partisan environment.
Two thirds of Americans want a ban on assault
rifles and semiautomatic weapons.
This is up seven points over the last 15 or
so months.
This is a very important change.
We already knew background checks were popular.
The Fox News poll finds that there is 90%
support for universal background checks, criminal
background checks on every gun, purchase and
sale.
Uh, however it is across party lines, 90%
of Democrats want universal background checks.
90% of Republicans want universal background
checks.
This is not common in the United States.
So listen, um, it's clear why Trump's approval
is dropping.
You have mat mass violence events.
When Barack Obama presided over mass violence
events, he would empathize with the victims
in a genuine way.
It's not that much to ask for, but he did
it.
Donald Trump attacks political opponents doubles
down on bad ideas.
Take smiling, thumbs up pictures with a baby
just orphaned by the mass shooting.
So it makes sense.
But even still, even though the trend line
is going towards disapproval, how does 40%
of the countries still approve of the job
this man is doing?
How does nearly a third of the country think
that Donald Trump's actions are pulling the
country together?
When the obvious a reality is the opposite
of that?
How clueless do you have to be to look at
what's going on and come away with that opinion?
So at the micro level, can we just pass background
checks?
I mean, 90% of the country wants them.
Can we just get it done at the macro level?
We see all of this data.
We see Trump's disapproval climbing.
We see Trump's polling underwater in a bunch
of swing states for the 2020 election.
Bernie Biden, Warren, all polling ahead of
Trump and hypothetical matchups, but are we
going to remove him or are we going to blow
it?
That's my question.
I'm on Twitter at the pacman.
The show
is
on
twitter@davidpakmanshowandmakesureyouaregettingmylivestreamsontwitchattwitch.tv